belichick he had his pre-draft press
conference today the guy doesn't talk
very often out of season in season he
talks all the time out of season doesn't
talk very often and he spoke miles about
a topic that was very relevant a couple
of weeks ago when owner robert kraft
said a few things that maybe constituted
a little a little
snide commental criticism a little slam
of the draft process here's belichick
talking about changes they've made this
year in new england
well we're always you know always
looking to do to get better um always
try to evaluate everything we do and try
to find a better way to to do it so
that's
that's a
i would say an annual process with the
draft but it's something that we do
on a regular basis throughout the course
of the season whether it's
you know whatever period of time it is
so
um you know always looking to to do a
better job there were some things that
last year that were unique to the draft
process as i mentioned some of those are
similar this year some of them are a
little bit different
so we you know certainly
use some of that experience to
improve the process a little bit this
year at least we felt we improved it
this year
but ultimately we're still going to try
to
evaluate the players and and make the
decisions that we feel like are best for
the football team
there had been a report a few weeks back
after robert kraft said what he said
albert brewer of si.com reporting that
belichick in the past has gone off the
board gone against the preferences
defied the rankings of his scouts most
notably with receiver and keel harry
round one two years ago when the scouts
had guys like debo samuel and aj brown
higher than harry and
what's happened harry has not been good
samuel and brown have been great
samuel banged up some but when he's
available he's really good but you know
miles i i this is a refreshing bill
belichick could it be that one day shy
of turning 69
he's starting to realize life's too
short to be miserable all the time
wouldn't that be great if he's if he's
realizing that he should not spend his
remaining years dour and somber and
miserable all the time well like you
said i mean he's turning 69 and maybe he
just wants to be nice for a change i
think that when you see bill belichick
and he's speaking the way he is i mean
he's basically just saying a lot of
words right that don't necessarily mean
all that much and that's what a lot of
head coaches do
when you're in the pre-draft process but
today i mean he was asked different
questions about different things but
it's not like he was answering the
questions really he just said a lot of
different words like i'm not sure how
much he really answered what it is that
they're doing differently this year he
talked about how yes there is some sort
of different processes that have had to
happen in the last couple of years
that's pretty obvious because kovid made
that the same for everybody right so i
think that there's maybe that aspect of
it but also i don't know maybe he feels
maybe reinvigorated you know like i said
maybe he's just going into your 69 he
wants to be a little bit nicer if that's
the case great for him but i still think
once we get to the season he's gonna be
you know the same guy that he's always
been mr mumbles
it's entirely possible though that he
has finally figured out what nick saban
has known for years which is that
it is
it is possible
to smile
to say things
to let the reporters feel like they're
getting answers even though when they go
back and look at the transcript they're
going to i didn't say anything but at
least the process isn't like pulling
teeth
out of an agitated alligator it's it's
more pleasant i'm holding out hope i'm
holding out hope that we're going to see
although i you know i'll end up missing
the mumbling
miserable bill belichick because it adds
flavor to the nfl but he did say matt
patricia former lions coach has been
more involved in the draft process there
had been reports of patricia being
actually involved
in
negotiating free agent contracts signing
on behalf of the team the cam newton
contract i saw somewhere signed by matt
patricia last year that same contract
signed by nick casario so different
things happening matt patricia not
officially on the coaching staff but
he's there and he's involved and he's
assisting and i it's it's a new day in
new england i i just i like this vibe i
like this feeling here's more from bill
belichick on
drafting at 15 in round one miles and
the possibility of trading up if the
opportunity arises
i think that it
again each drafts a little bit different
and and uh
so each year is a little bit different
but all that being said
um
you know at 15 i think we could
eliminate a few players that won't be at
15
and then you could look at a couple
scenarios and say well if
you know these three players are there
which one we take if
these other three different players were
there which one would you take you know
you go through that exercise and
and and talk about that but i would say
normally
something now there's less options at 15
than there are
you know 28 30 31
you know some other spots that we
drafted from but
um
i would say normally something will
happen and and there could very well be
a player there that
uh either
you don't expect to be there or
maybe he is a couple spots maybe at 12
13 he's still on the board
and he really thought that he'd be gone
in the top six seven picks
and then that and you know then the
question comes you know do you move up
and try to get that player that's fallen
a little bit
you know if i could do a really good
john madden impersonation i would read
that answer from the transcript because
that just smacks of the kind of obvious
stuff
that we always heard he didn't say
anything well you see we got picked
number 15 and there may be a player
there that we take at number 15. and we
don't have to stay there what we could
do see is trade up if we see an
opportunity to do that do you understand
and then maybe we don't maybe we do we
can but we don't have to we can stay
where we are he's figuring out
the words don't matter he doesn't have
to be afraid that he's going to open his
mouth and inadvertently
reveal his draft board i feel like he's
always been that way like every time he
has a press conference he's being
interrogated by opposing forces behind
enemy lines no it doesn't have to be
that way and it's a shame that he seems
to be figuring it out one day shy of his
69th birthday miles
i don't know i i think it's mostly just
the fact that we're in april and we are
he already knows that anything he says
is going to be used against him so he's
just saying a bunch of things that are
nothing although now that i think about
it i have seen him do uh pre-draft press
conferences where it definitely is like
pulling teeth for him so maybe you're
right maybe he is just learning things
and maybe i don't know a losing season
and maybe he got some more sleep in
january and february because he wasn't
in the super bowl like it seems he is
every single year and you know he just
wants to turn a new leaf wants to do
something a little bit differently but i
think the thing that like i just find
interesting about the patriots is that
everything has to be like fort knox i
mean like you were just talking about
the fact that matt patricia
is now doing different things inside of
the patriots complex what exactly is
matt patricia's title and why don't we
get to know i don't really understand
why it is that we don't get to know like
every other team in the league what
people's titles are and what jobs they
have there look i looked on the patriots
website just to be sure of this because
i just want to say like maybe they have
it somewhere no they don't you know what
they do have they have jed fish still
listed as the quarterbacks coach he has
been in arizona as the head coach of the
university of arizona since december i
don't get that why can't we just know
like every other team what people's
titles are
well ernie adams has been there as long
as bill belichick and we still don't
know what the hell his title is or what
the hell he does he's just ernie adams
and i think matt patricia is developing
into this new age ernie adams where he's
just gonna be doing stuff we don't know
what he's got project special project
what's his title nobody knows he just
shows up shows up glares at you pulls
the pencil out of his ear makes a note
puts it back walks away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports